[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody and Happy
New Year hot ones fans this is Sean
Evans checking in with some exciting
news the season 5 premiere of hot ones
will be next week that's right
Thursday at 11 a.m. we fire up the
chainsaw and you know what that means
new year new sauces it's out with the
old and in with the new
this season's lineup is pound for pound
the hottest and hot ones history the
most scovilles on the table but you know
we're always learning we're always
thinking we're always evolving so in
addition to being the hottest this is
also in our opinion the most balanced
Heat progression that we've ever had
season four it was full of bucket
spinning and spice spasms and dry heaves
but often times the party wouldn't
really get started until wing number
seven with zombie apocalypse this one we
have a few more early body blows some
fizzle some sizzle that'll hopefully put
our guests on their feet earlier and
then boom ramped it up even harder at
the end so we'll see how that goes they
don't teach that in J school right there
Chris Schoenberger to set the table
this season's leadoff hitter humble
house on show and mereta
sriracha was no big deal Valentina no
big deal and guess what
ancho and Morita no big deal but it is
delicious with a smoky barbecue flavor
that goes great with wings or vegan
nuggets if you're into that sort of
thing at number 2 the original Louisiana
Hot Sauce
for those of you taking notes at home
you'll notice a trend here at the number
2 spot always a vinegar-based hot sauce
out of Louisiana
Tabasco held it down for a while crystal
it did its tour of duty and now we have
Louisiana the original it's been smoking
people out since 1928 the real ones know
at number 3 the Bronx green market sauce
Brooklyn and Queen Majesty had their
moment in the Sun for two straight years
and now it's time to show some love for
the BX on a pound-for-pound level I'm
calling it right now may be the tastiest
sauce that we've ever had on the
Serrano Chili's onion garlic bellissimo
and then here's a fun fact for you
socially conscious chili heads out there
and I know that there are many the
peppers used in this sauce are grown in
community gardens all over the Bronx
look at that hot sauce making the world
a better place at number four what the
what the what the Oh what's this your
old favorite hot ones very Chipotle
going from number five to number four
somebody call the authorities what does
this mean is the hot ones gauntlet
getting hotter how is this going to
affect explain that Gramm all valid
questions but ultimately sometimes you
just have to shake that etch-a-sketch
clean and just start a new masterpiece
and so we're moving on to a new number
five this is adobo loco ham a Jiang hot
ones trivia Lert the first hot sauce
that we've had from the great state of
Hawaii
shout out to hot ones super producer
Sarah Honda apple cider vinegar smoked
ghost peppers habanero sea salt if you
like them smoky this is the sauce for
you and it's also a little bit of a
creeper so expect guests to just shrug
it off and then boom
get smacked upside the face with some
scovilles at number six karma sauce
extreme karma I'm a little bit worried
about this one because it has some
serious firepower at number six our
guests are going to learn very quickly
that this is some next-level [ __ ] it has
three peppers from the super hot
category scorpion Trinidad and ghost but
from a flavor perspective it's actually
one of the more interesting sauces that
we've had with butternut squash red
pepper sweet potato get your karma jokes
ready and then at number seven the heat
train doesn't slow down one bit we're
coming in with some dawson's and let's
just take a moment to admire this
beautiful bottle you know hot sauce it's
always flames from Hell in
skull-and-crossbones but it doesn't need
to be sometimes you can have some
integrity some art in the label but
don't get it twisted
because
this is a serious heater it'll just boom
zoom straight to the moon and we're not
stopping there at number eight it's the
face melter you know it dub bomb it's a
classic and it's not going anywhere
guests hate it and if it ain't broke
don't fix it de bomb keeps its place at
the table I would not want to face the
type of wave of backlash that hot ones
fans would have if we took it off so
don't worry de bomb we've screwed it in
it's been cemented in its place it ain't
going anywhere and we have some exciting
news I know that you saw it you're
looking at it from the second we popped
to the wide-angle mad dog makes its
return to the hot ones table but before
I talk about this hot sauce I think that
it's important that we have a moment of
silence for Blair's mega death sauce
with liquid rage a Hall of Fame hot
sauce
Steven shut up Chris shut up everyone
quiet quiet quiet
okay raise that Blair's Megadeath sauce
Jersey to the rafters and now let's talk
about the return of Mad Dog it's a
million Scoville plus addition sauce the
Holy Trinity of Reapers scorpions ghost
peppers peep the gold bullet on the side
its menacing hot ones it's a game that's
very mental and then you know for the
people out there who are like but I miss
liquid rage what about the liquid rage
oh the liquid rage worry not this has
plutonium number nine plutonium number
nine I don't know a plutonium number
nine is but I do have a feeling that
it's going to ruin some press runs and
now we've almost got to the top of the
mountain I can see the summit BAM it's
here the last dab and this year's
harvest of pepper acts significantly
hotter than last year's harvest of
pepper acts and then you can even see it
in the bottle it used to have sort of a
light green tint and now it's this
beautiful orange color and that's
because there's just so much of pepper X
in this sauce that as it evolves so
- will the color of the sauce and that's
hot ones in a nutshell always changing
always evolving highly unpredictable and
there you have it it's the hot ones
season five gauntlet now you have your
playing cards if you'd like to play
along at home and of course if you can't
find some of these go into the archives
but we'll be right back with you next
week it's the season 5 premiere thank
you so much to the hot ones fans who've
rocked with us since day 1 season 1
those who are there at season 2 who
racked with us in season 3 who watched
us in season 4 now into season 5 and
hopefully beyond that we'll see you next
week
where were you one
uh-huh that's Melbourne hmm he's gone
all right moving on to number seven and
another one with some volume this oh
[ __ ] I [ __ ] that up didn't I I went
from wait wait right yeah okay it will
be a classic Outlands continuity here no
one's gonna know hello hot ones fans its
Sean Evans new outro same message if you
like what just saw throw us a bone maybe
please it is dog-eat-dog here on the
YouTube streets hit that subscribe
button
knowing that you subscribed it is
seriously the only thing that gets me
out of bed in the morning thank you very
much hot ones fans I love you